[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy leftist media bias is not limited
to the New York Times Washington Post
CNN and the rest it operates at every
level of the establishment media
recently The Argus leader in Sioux Falls
South Dakota published a piece that is a
textbook example of how leftist
journalists so-called
present news articles designed to
manipulate the public into holding the
views they want them to hold Argus
leader reporter Joe Steve tells us that
Mike Gunn a retired business owner and a
dark horse in the 2018 Sioux Falls
mayoral race drew attention from the
nonprofit South Dakota voices for
justice for a series of Facebook posts
expressing support for tighter
immigration laws and alarmism over the
country's increasing Muslim population
so right off the bat we have Mike gun
against the South Dakota voices for
justice which makes it sound as if gun
is against justice the candidates crime
was actually that he shared posts from
the Facebook page of Americans first
task force of Aberdeen South Dakota
which Steve calls a self-described
educational page that regularly shares
memes and news stories critical of Islam
you see it's a self-described
educational page steve is semaphore that
readers should approach this group with
skepticism and what posted guns share
the post in question included a story
from the website jihad watch comm
stating the Council on american-islamic
relations care is tied to terrorist
organizations similar claims have been
made by Republican and conservative
office seekers throughout the country
who cite a Center for security policy
report linking the organization to
terrorist groups in the Middle East now
the way Steve wrote that gives readers
the impression that jihad Watch which is
the website that I operate and the
center for security policy are
responsible for the claim that care is
tied to terrorist organizations so I
wrote to Joe Steve and I pointed out
that it was not
I or the CSP who stated that care was
tied to terrorist organizations but the
United States Justice Department that
said it and I sent him a link to an
investigative project on terrorism
report to substantiate what I was saying
that explained fully how the Justice
Department had identified care as tied
to Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood
Steve however wrote back saying that
after consulting with his editor they
had decided not to change the wording of
their story sneeze story then goes on to
say but the Southern Poverty Law Center
a non-profit legal advocacy organization
specializing in civil rights and public
interest litigation has repeatedly
defended care and says the Center for
security policy is an anti Muslim
extremist group in my email to Steve I
also wrote I wonder if you're familiar
with the charges that the Southern
Poverty Law Center is not a neutral
arbiter of what constitutes an extremist
group and what does not but has been
harshly and justifiably criticized for
turning a blind eye to Islamist
extremist groups such as care while
defaming legitimate conservative
organizations such as the CSP with their
extremist label Steve never answered
that one note also that he describes the
SPLC as a non-profit legal advocacy
organization specializing in civil
rights and public interest litigation in
contrast to how he treated the Americans
first group Steve slaps no
self-described qualifier on his
description of the SPLC despite
considerable evidence that it is by no
means a neutral arbiter but a hard left
smear group that uses its extremists
label DEET are legitimate groups that
oppose its leftist agenda now Joe Steve
is no different from hordes of other
establishment media self-described
reporters in larger markets it is
virtually universal practice for
mainstream reporters to treat Hamas
linked care and the defamation factory
SPLC
as if they were reliable sources and to
force conservatives such as mic gun to
defend themselves against their charges
in a sane world people such as Mike gun
would be lauded for their determination
to defend the nation and the story would
be about Joe Smith and the
Argos leader of Sioux Falls South Dakota
and their manipulative propaganda spin
designed to intimidate and shame people
such as Mike gun into being afraid to
stand for the national defense but
you're only going to hear about that on
one of the Internet's few and rapidly
diminishing islands of sanity
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]